the ukrainians have been preparing for
months for a spring offensive that's
shifting to the summer
and the pressures building as they seek
to reclaim their lands
but in this slick looking video produced
by Ukraine's military they tell us
they'll fight where and when they see
fit
plans love silence says the caption
there'll be no announcement about the
start
yet both sides are fighting and the
Russians have decided to call it
themselves the offensive has begun says
their military spokesman
the enemy launched a large-scale attack
in five sectors said Igor konoshenkov
but it had no successes
we've seen claim and counterclaim in the
past 24 hours Rebel Fighters saying
they're in possession of villages in
Russia's belgarod region while the
Russians say they destroyed a Ukrainian
unit in kuzima there are claims the
ukrainians have taken burkhifka near
bakmut while the Russians say they've
killed up to 425 Ukrainian troops in
southern Donetsk so the
counter-offensives began says Russia but
the experts aren't so sure I think what
we're seeing is what I would Define as
probing tax uh along the front line to
identify uh the kind of force that um
the ukraines will be faced with
um the the size and the type of Russian
forces that are defending those those
areas the Russians say a large-scale
attack is underway in South Donetsk and
Sky's data and forensic unit have
verified a series of videos from the
area all published in the last 24 hours
here we see tanks in close combat near
the village of Novo darifka
and eight kilometers Northeast in the
same area we've pinpointed footage
released by the Russian defense Ministry
where a number of military vehicles are
targeted
but we haven't seen evidence of a major
thrust by the ukrainians along with the
use of Western tanks like the leopard or
the Challenger
thank you very much what we have seen is
the UK's foreign secretary James
cleverley in Kiev where he reassured his
hosts of Britain's continued support
when we made the commitment publicly
that we would continue backing you
and your country until you are
victorious in your self-defense we meant
it and Senior officials in Ukraine now
say they are moving to offensive
operations
the tempo of war is rising John Sparks
Sky News